hey so guys my name is eterno welcome
back to the series in which I remake my
first game that I made in Java in C plus
plus
LIVE edition because we're live on
Twitch twitch.tv slash the channel for
those of you who don't know where I live
stream I decided to kind of potentially
mix up the format of the series a little
bit thank you marmalade K4 or whatever
for subscribing appreciate the squad
um yeah there we go we are on Twitch uh
I thought I would mix up the format a
little bit just because
um I kind of want to get this done uh
like as quickly as possible almost
because I don't want this to be another
series that I never finish and also
because I have some exciting ideas for
the future on how we can carry this a
little bit further and maybe use this as
a basis to implement some pretty cool uh
other technology like multiplayer so
we'll see how that goes
um okay so let's dive in uh we're gonna
basically work on tiles today last
episode if you didn't catch that on
YouTube We
uh loaded levels so I'll have that
linked up there on YouTube and uh
without further Ado let's dive in and
take a look alright so
um basically what we have at the moment
in the C plus plus side of things is
this so we have our like a fuse price
rendering we have the whole level being
rendered so now that we have this
uh thanks um I remind aestheticus I
don't know how to pronounce that I'm
just assuming 20 months though damn
appreciate the sport maybe I should turn
the sub notifications off for YouTube I
don't know but thank you guys I do
appreciate the support
um so basically if we take a look at
this
um obviously what we're doing here is
we're loading this level we're just
displaying it we're just rendering it
kind of copying the pixels right onto
the actual image that is our screen but
what we need to do is go through kind of
every pixel here and read its color and
use the color to determine what kind of
tile should be in that kind of position
in the world and then depending on where
our camera is
we're gonna obviously have like a
viewport into the world uh and we only
want to render the tiles that are kind
of in that camera view because rendering
all of these tiles well first of all is
not exactly going to work because
they're going to be off the screen so
we're going to kind of end up not
rendering those pixels anyway
um but also it's going to be a pain to
go through like I think this is 128 by
128 so like that's a fair few pixels to
kind of get through
um well sorry 128 by 128 tiles to render
would be a fair few to just try and
render every single frame uh if at the
end of the day you're only going to be
rendering like I don't know a few
hundred so
um that's basically the plan so if we
look at how Java does this
um
it's
well actually I don't even think we need
to look at that yet because what we need
to do is at the moment in level render
again what we're doing is we're grabbing
the actual final screen buffer and then
we're setting it to just be the tile ID
which we read from the tile so the tiles
is the actual s like load level from
file that's the kind that's the kind um
kind of actual texture that we're that
we're reading in that is our level so we
have that inside M tiles and that's
exactly what Java did uh because I am
trying to kind of Port this almost one
to one but I will be
um you know trying to improve things I
guess along the way as well so if we
look at this uh yeah this is us reading
in the tiles
um and that's kind of again exactly
where they're going we also have this
grass I didn't actually see if grass was
used I know it's used up here but is
grass actually used anywhere
I have a feeling it might not be
yeah oh no it is
so if tiles is that color and grass is
zero then we return tile grass so I
guess it might be used here which is
good so I didn't just do that for no
reason but if we take a look at what
rendering really does
um and in fact we could even just copy
this as a basis
um
but we'll take a look at that in a
minute I think because the idea is to go
through this add a particular camera
offset which is what x scroll and Y
scroll is and then just simply look up
which tile we need to do when we need to
render here
um but it's kind of coordinate in the
world and then call tile.randa which is
not a great way of doing it I would have
done the rendering in here these days
um or at least I don't know on the other
hand is level it's just we're kind of go
to no I probably would have done
something like screen dot render tile
right and just had that done here I
think part of the reason why it's done
like this though is because you can
override this and there might actually
be
like for example ocean tile
is a water tile yeah see there's an
animation thing and it's going to render
a different Sprite depending on where it
is so this is like why we have this kind
of uh class hierarchy here because it
ends up being
um it actually ends up being like kind
of them there ends up being some
behavior that might be tied to certain
tile types so it's somewhat important to
kind of do that I don't know if I still
will just because you can say we up we
do switch between these two here will
there be a better way of doing that
though I don't know
it's just what we could do
is alternative alternatively back in
like a level
uh here it is um back in level if we
going to get tile we could have just had
some logic here that says okay well fine
if you want to return a water tile then
just have a think about which Sprite it
is that you need to return
um that may have been better
but anyway let's not do that now
um let's just kind of keep the same
behavior and so the first thing I want
to do is if we go into surprise at the
moment we just have grass which is two
and seven and if we take a look at our
Sprite sheet so two and seven was it
from the bottom from this English from
the top right so two seven or two seven
is wrong anyway it should be like zero
and three so this is grass so let's
start by trying to render that I don't
think these are even used actually this
one might be I mean it's just a solid
color but
we'll see
um this I know is me is being used
because that's the grass thing and then
we have flowers and the rock as well
sorry what was that zero and three
so let's try and render grass and then
let's pick one more the water so one one
let's just do one one
and we'll make that water
well there's two frames for the water
animation
isn't there
these two so let's just do that for now
um I mean I might as well add like flour
and Rock
I guess
so flower is
what is that three uh three and four
wait what am I doing
I've confused my X and Y
'all feels like a call back to the
Flying Dog code review episode of how to
design the code around Sprites yeah
um
you know we the thing is like I'm kind
of doing this in two parts in my head
I'm on one hand like I'm trying to
concentrate on the actual existing
functionality because when you're
porting something
if you start also rewriting it as you go
it's very easy to miss little things and
because I want to obviously like at
least for the first iteration I want
this to be a real Port like I want this
to actually every single little finicky
behavior that was in the game I want to
replicate exactly it should visually
look the same I mean there's some bugs
that I want to fix but aside from that
like I don't want this to be a different
game initially at least right
um because then I have done my job
poorly so that's kind of the first
challenge of retaining this in its exact
format
um the next move after that is probably
going to be to take take it further by
again adding new features and maybe
tweaking it a little bit and also
tweaking the code to make maybe make it
perform better or just be better easier
to maintain extend that kind of thing
but first up I kind of do want to retain
the functionality
um
so that's so I'm still changing things
you know like I I never had anything
like that really
um you know every single Sprite inside
this game was actually kind of a new a
separate instance of a class I mean here
is a separate instance of a struct but
that's a bit different but also it's a
separate instance of a class which
actually has its own buffer that it
allocates
right so you have a 16 by 16 sized
buffer
um that every single Sprite has so we
don't do that anymore because we just
read the pixels we need directly from
the single Sprite shade kind of buffer
which is going to be a lot better than
each of these having an allocation
somewhere in memory
um so that's uh you know we are still
changing stuff up where it makes sense
but not like completely basically is the
idea
all right so
now by the way those of you watching on
YouTube let me know what you think about
this format like you know it's kind of
nice I guess that I can answer questions
from chat um kind of in real time and
also it's just a bit more relaxed a bit
more chill and I'll still try and keep
episodes like around 30 minutes or so
30 to 40 minutes but I'll still kind of
try and do them by topic so today kind
of we're working on obviously the kind
of rendering tiles and Sprites all right
cool so
um the next big thing now is I want to
be able to tell this renderer to render
a spry like I want to be like hey
draw me a Sprite and I have draw Sprite
but you can see it takes an X index and
Y index which is almost correct
um as in that's part of what we want
because we do want a Sprite right so
this tell this lets us kind of pass
around a Sprite
uh so let me just include
um Sprite which is good because I can do
kind of one of these
um which is going to be one of one of
these and you can see I'm not passing
this by const reference or anything
because it's just like it's eight bytes
of data so there's really no need to do
that
um but then I also need to tell it where
in the world I want it to render right
and specifically obviously there is no
concept of world there's just screen
um because when like as far as this
image buffer is concerned you're
rendering pixels on the screen and this
over here I think is zero zero right I
don't think it's down here for this kind
of version I mean am I might might be
it's just worth flipping the image at
some point so anyway so I think that's
the top so the point is I can't be like
I'll render it at 10 000 by whatever and
then it'll clip it or whatever it
doesn't understand that like it is
always zero zero there's no camera this
is the renderer everything you render is
in this range of width and height
basically because this is the screens
buffer so that means that I also need to
provide it like basically okay which
Sprite do you want to render and where
so we're gonna just use I guess X and Y
to indicate where we want that to be
rendered on the screen
um and then we'll pass in the Sprite as
well does that make sense or should we
pass in this product first then a
coordinate no idea
but let's implement this guy
um okay and then you can you can kind of
see what we used to do here uh so I'm
going to copy this because it's actually
not bad because we get the Sprite sheet
you can see and then we're able to read
from there but this XC and YC is really
like this is the x coordinate and y
coordinate I believe of the Sprite
because it gets multiplied by Sprite
size here so we can actually get rid of
that and just use Sprite X and Y
directly so this becomes Sprite X and we
should do some bounce checking at some
point
but we'll see
um
this is out of bounds okay so we do
actually do bounce checking which is
good
um
all right
so
someone asked in chat earlier how long
have I been programming for like uh like
12 years probably since like 2011. I
mean I did some kind of programming in
2006 as early as then but really like
with Java I started in 2011.
um Okay so
yeah yeah so now with now that we have
this is our world space kind of position
all we need to do really is when it
comes down to us actually putting this
somewhere let's look at where it goes in
the image buffer so XT plus X so XT
um
uh plus x x is the offset for the Sprite
XT at the moment is yeah the middle X so
it this is actually the position so this
can go away uh basically uh because it's
just X and Y
um
I might call this y s for y Sprite so
that just stands for
uh I need to make sure I get that
everywhere because this x is now taken
over
so this is the surprise so we shouldn't
have X anyway here I'm just relying on
the highlighting here to make sure
um and then what I need to do is get
into basically World space so this looks
at the Sprite sheet which this is
somewhat correct why is it using XP for
this
odd okay so XP is
the beginning of this Pro okay so this
is a bit confusing but XP is basically
like I'll kind of Lay It lay it down
here even though I should probably just
give the variables better names but at
the moment this is it so X Y is World
space Oh sorry not well space screen
space
uh pixel position
of where to render
uh x p y p
um is the
uh
start of sprite inside Sprite sheet
and x uh x s y s
is
uh Sprite pixel
in local space so basically from zero to
zero to Fifteen
inclusive
um
so that's a little reference guide here
so the screen okay so we definitely need
to offset by that to get into here but
we need to before we do that we need to
basically be like
uh are we rendering in the right place
okay and then there's xtny so X10 YT is
that right x10yt is X and Y
um it's just that we used to render
right out of the middle of the screen by
doing this so this can all go away
um and now XT and YT basically become X
and Y but wait we need to make sure that
we're in the bounds here right because
otherwise if we go off the screen this
is going to crash because it's going to
be outside of the buffer so we need to
make sure basically that where we're
planning on rendering which is this so
I'm going to make a new one which is
going to be
x t y t
render Target pixel
coordinate right so this obviously
includes this offset and it includes
everything
um so in XT is going to be X Plus XS was
it's literally this it's just I'm
putting it into a variable so that I can
check clipping
and we might do clipping in a better way
in the future
but for now we'll just do it this way
um okay so if x t uh is less than zero
or YT is less than zero for now we'll do
it this way this is just the easy way
um and width
so this means we can't render it and
we're just going to continue right which
again is not the best thing to do
because it might be completely outside
of the screen and we can't do anything
but we can do the clipping kind of
earlier so I'm going to say to do uh do
initial clipping here
so hopefully that kind of makes sense it
does to me
um
but
uh let's first make sure this works and
then maybe I'll explain it again
um
I don't know let's see if this works so
let's and remember that's the complete
screen position so if I then go back to
level and I basically say Okay draw me
maybe after we do the map draw me a
Sprites the first thing is a chord isn't
it so add zero zero draw me a grass
Sprite
right and then at let's do something
like close to the middle of the screen
so well
let's just do like 400 or like 500 by
500.
maybe I'll do how big is that gonna be
let's just do 600 by 450 or something so
it's not uniform so we can test that out
and we can do the flower
let's see what happens
yeah the the software's called zoom in
okay so the grass worked I mean that
doesn't look like my grass though
um that just looks like the
the green thing
it should be three zero
which should be this grass oh that's
actually two zero
actually messes up it doesn't work
anyway but because we would have got
enough flower
but that's a bit weird isn't it and then
I didn't get my other one at all
so I've clearly done that wrong which is
actually kind of good
because it means I get to debug it and
that might be useful for people
um
uh yeah and I'm definitely doing this
stuff on top of this because I'm doing
this first
so therefore
it should have probably worked
um okay so Sprite x times Sprite size so
this gets us in the right place within
the Sprite thing we're not getting any
errors being out of bounds which is good
then we're going to Loop through
this right size here
um we're gonna basically look at this
the spreadsheet pixels XP aha so XP plus
XS is that correct yes
yes so this goes through the spreadsheet
pixels and just make sure that we're not
drawing a transparent color next up
um so we should we should really be
sampling from the right spot
I believe unless again it's doing that
weird thing where it's flipped but it
wouldn't be because we are getting that
grass
so two so air
this should really be like
two two times sixteen so 32 is should be
the beginning of this which it is and
then that's just the offset for each
pixel that should definitely be correct
I have no idea why that's not working
um and then we're writing it into are we
writing into the right spot well this is
just going to be
ah
oh well no that makes sense as well
doesn't it yeah that should make sense
this should this should be working are
we we're not clipping are we
no idea why that's not working no it
doesn't look like it I mean I'm in
release mode
but that is so weird
okay we're gonna have to debug it so
into debug mode we go
really strange probably something like a
little oversight somewhere
I'm scanning the code just trying to
find it now but I don't really know why
we're definitely loading that Sprite
chick correctly right
Ah that's been fixed
in a different place
so let's see if that ever happens okay
that does happen see that shouldn't
happen
ah because the width is not in pixels
it's divided by three so that's why
we're not getting our flower so let's
see if we get our flower
because I was doing it I thought like
with window but obviously it's getting
scaled up by three so let's just like I
don't know half this or something or get
a kind of a lot a lot smaller we'll see
if we get this
yeah we still get the same one so we're
definitely reading the wrong pixel we're
always reading that top left one which
doesn't make any sense so let's kind of
uh put a breakpoint here
because this is us trying to render just
down almost prior right so why
um
like what color are we trying to
retrieve here so zero
Sprite X is zero
you want mate
oh no
it's because I over over rode this
so when I was showing you guys how like
the inline keyword Works in a past
episode I specifically wrote this
Constructor here and this doesn't set X
and Y to anything so it's always zero
so let's get rid of this entirely we
don't need it yeah
should always undo code that you add
just improved points
um all right there you go so we have our
grass in the top left as promised and
then here's our beautiful flower
so now it obviously
makes a lot of sense
and we've got water and everything
uh now it obviously makes a lot of sense
to just be like why don't we do this but
times 100 or whatever right so in level
render at the moment we're just doing
one Sprite but it's very easy for us
just to write a little Loop that goes
through let's just say the whole map
which we know is 128 but we can always
just ask the level
how big it is right
um
so we kind of go through this
and then we say draw me a Sprite
but now the type of sprite is going to
depend and also is this so this
obviously this width and height is going
to be whatever the size of the level is
in tile so this is not in pixels so how
do we get from pixels to tiles we have
to multiply it by the size of tiles
which is 16. now in the Java code
you saw me doing some cooler stuff
so if we now go to level render you can
see that's what's happening here right
so you can see me doing some slightly
cooler stuff uh actually this is
dividing but when am I doing uh no no
sorry I know where this is this isn't
like uh tiles right so they can water
Tile For example you can see I'm doing
um x shift left for y shifts left four
so this is the same thing as doing time
16. so instead of writing times 16 I'm
doing a shift level four
um this was considered some sort of
optimization potentially in Java back
then I definitely don't think it should
still apply because it's obviously easy
for the compiler to be like let me do
that but the point is that like if
you're ever multiplying or dividing by a
power of two compilers will usually
convert it to be for division a shift
right and for multiplication a shift
left if again it's by a power of two
because that's generally faster in terms
of like assembly instruction CPU kind of
instructions then actually doing a and
integer multiplication or division
so that's why so we could keep that
style here and in which case I would
just write that
but you don't really have to and again
it's four because 2 to the power of 4 is
16 and that's obviously the number that
we're multiplying by so that kind of 4
to get 16 which is what we want to
multiply by that becomes the subject of
this operation
so that's how that works
it makes the code look a bit cooler
though so that's really why we do it
okay so which Sprite do we want so
that's going to depend on where we are
in the level which is the X and Y
coordinate so basically
this is a very like not good way of
doing it but I'm going to quickly do it
um so what we need to do is we need to
basically grab that tile ID from earlier
right because you can see we're going
through X and Y here I can't I basically
wrote this whole Loop without even
seeing the one above here but as you can
see it's the same exact Loop
um
except I didn't do the units here which
not a not a big deal but this is a
comparison with a un so you should use
the same type if you can
um so what I can do now is I can grab
that so sure we can do this like little
uh check up here and this check down
here but uh like as long as that's good
and we should definitely be doing this
after the check obviously but if we look
at this
um
which is our tile ID we can now
basically assign a Sprite depending on
that tile ID
um and so we can kind of just be like
all right uh uh you know if
tile ID equals well I'll make it a
switch statement
for now again this will change but
switch
um in many case like let's look at what
should what it should be right so if we
go back to Java land we look at level we
look at the get tile function
which I just can call right off
unfortunately so the get tell function
you can see that for example uh so what
do we have there we've got like water
tiles there right so where's water
so what is this color so I can just grab
that probably
um put that in here and be like all
right well the Sprite in this case is
going to be Sprites water and we'll go
with water zero
um we can also do like grass and stuff I
guess
so let's look at what grass was
I mean there's a few different thoughts
here I think it's just this is it that
white it's white
it should be white it's white or uh what
looks like
it's hard to tell that's that's probably
yellow it's just I don't know if the red
Channel's here because the red Channel
might be there
um because it might be a BGR
but anyway
um let's go with the grass for now which
is we're probably gonna mostly see ocean
but our grass is just white
um so let's digress uh and then we'll
draw obviously there's Sprite
so and we're doing that on top of the
level so we actually won't see this
anymore
we could have flipped it the other round
but there you go all right so we have
this here which uh
probably not what I would have expected
I will kind of would have expected water
um now the other thing is what happens
if it's neither of these then we just
draw okay so we see Zero Zero if it's
neither so it's neither so I have a
feeling that it might be flipped
so this might be FF and 3A so let's try
that and we'll see if we get water yeah
there you go so it is flipped there was
a bit of weirdness over here like some
weird clipping or something and if we
resize this by the way we see um it kind
of gets bigger like the whole map but we
could say more of the map which is kind
of fun oh that was the scroll bar that's
what was flickering there
um all right cool yeah so it has to be
reversed compared to Java so that's an
important distinction
um so this is the red channel in uh our
card whereas it's the other way around
in Java this is the blue channel so it's
a argb in Java and ABG are in in uh see
what's possible using sdb image again is
really the reason
Okay cool so I'd like to see more of the
level now
um now I could do something fun I could
probably just make stretch this out over
two monitors
and you guys can't see this but I'm
about to move it and you can see that we
see our Island now right now obviously
we have a lot of grass clumps here which
we're not supposed to
um but that's because
uh we're supposed to be doing some other
kind of checks
um so you can see we're trying to do
grass so only if grass equals zero do we
then return tile grass otherwise we'll
return I guess void tile really
what's void Sprite it's bright zero so
maybe that's the top left one really
grass grounds
no that's that has to be a different one
because that's that's this oh that's a
black one yeah
okay so that means that
we should be getting grass ground
somewhere shouldn't we
oh here it is
so if it's FF so this is a bit weird
you can see I kind of so I've got this
in a few places so I've got this check
against white here and here
um but it's also acceptable to be this
which is predominantly a green color
um
and then we return gross ground so
basically we only do grass if it's zero
otherwise we do a grass ground so if we
really wanted to kind of make that a bit
better if it's FF for example for now
let's just basically check grass right
so we can check grass
at X Plus y times width and if that's
zero then we do grass otherwise we do
the Sprite called grass ground
and grass ground which doesn't exist yet
is
zero zero
so let's try that so now we should get
it a lot
um
yeah a lot fewer and it's also randomly
generated I know
all right so there you go pretty cool
um and then finally obviously like we
don't really want to have this weird
system of having a switch statement here
and doing all this stuff here instead
what would be a lot better is to have a
get tile function like we did here now
you can see in this case again it
returns an actual tile which we might
not do we'll see
um probably not though uh because I
don't really want to and then you can
see over here that we take in a
coordinate and we take in that
coordinate just so that we can do X Plus
y times width
I don't know if that's worth doing
um like
because instead of taking that in
we could just work out the coordinate
here
and then pass that in
to work out this right so it's up to you
like you could pass in X Y I guess it
maybe is more intuitive in a way
um
I'll call this get tile Sprite
it might be more intuitive in a way to
just be like hey please tell me what
Sprite what Sprite should be at this
index like at this coordinate you know
rather than like here's a tile ID
or here's a Sprite ID tell me what
Sprite should be there you know
I'm not 100 sure
um but let's just write this version
first because it's the same as a Java
one
uh and so I'll grab my switch statement
move it here
um we'll get the tile ID by doing this
the problem is you already kind of need
a bounce check potentially here whereas
this bounce check happens here in this
case
um so maybe it would have been better I
don't know because otherwise like X and
Y like if you go off the map or
something weird this could crash because
well it'll be like a memory access
violation
so I'm not really sure
um on the bright side though we could
keep this as
uh
this kind of stuff
um as a switch statement and it would
probably be a little cleaner which just
returns like this I mean it's the same
thing honestly as having those if
statements there but that's a potential
thing we could do
um and then let's just return well there
should be a void tile but let's just
return water if
there's
ah
all prints invalid
tile ID
um
now what else was I thinking of yeah so
I like the other thing here though is
that we definitely don't need to be
doing something like this
um you know when I was kind of young
Cherno I didn't really understand how
Maps worked
um like hash maps and stuff so what I
did was I just had an if check here just
checking with like every single ID and
returning what it's supposed to be
um now some of this somewhat makes sense
just because it's based on like that you
can put some logic in here so for
example you can see that we return This
Grass tile uh not every time but
dependent on not just what the tile ID
is that maps to grass but also whether
or not the grass is here right
like whether or not grassy is zero
because there's a one in eight chance
for us to actually have the grass tile
as opposed to just the grass ground tile
which is what happens in the other cases
so that's probably one of the reasons
why
um it's not that simple but otherwise
you could obviously just have a hash map
of like tile IDs that map to Sprites in
this case or to tiles in the future and
that might be a little bit better to
kind of do
um
but yeah again it's not necessarily
uh important it's just uh an idea and
again like the problem is that in for
cases like this it would be perfect you
know if you're just doing that it would
be perfect again not that I expect the
performance to be dramatically different
in fact I don't know like this almost
seems like it might be faster because it
doesn't have to I'm sure it's probably
not but like it's just a branch versus
like a hash function
I don't know to be honest but um yeah
that is obviously something that
you can think about but again you lose
extra logic that you can do such as this
um but other than that uh does that work
now I'll get tile Sprite let's just do
equals get tile Sprite X Y so you can
see we don't need this anymore we just
kind of do that oh sorry microphone
all right okay so we do have an invalid
tile ID apparently
don't know where from
uh because I was going to say it's kind
of working but there's oh is this
supposed to be water here
is I think there is supposed to be water
there if we quickly look at um
our level which is I think the ocean one
no okay so there's supposed to be uh
these kind of green things here
which are we just haven't gotten around
to them all right okay because what we
added is now if it doesn't have if it's
not valid it returns water that's why
um but yeah that's it I think that's it
for today's episode hope you guys
enjoyed uh again this is like now live
on Twitch I guess switch on TV channels
where I live stream usually and wear
this series I guess is now found as home
um but next time we're gonna dive in and
do uh probably a camera so that we can
like move around this world
um and we'll just do like the rest of
the tiles I guess and see how that works
out so thank you thank you guys for
watching uh and I'll see you next time
goodbye